what's going on guys this is rob and
let's talk about the moon night finale
obviously there's going to be spoilers
in this video just fyi
there was good and bad with this moon
night finale it followed your typical
marvel finale right like literally a
giant alligator fighting a giant
skeleton looking guy while their avatars
fight down on the surface i mean it's
marvel right it if it follows part and
parcel with the marvel thing
in truth it was okay um i really
wouldn't say it was bad i wouldn't say
it was great the show as a whole i think
had its high points and its low points i
think the finale just kind of falls in a
medium path and in all honesty i think
that's maybe one of the biggest issues
that marvel kind of contends with at the
moment is that while the the marvel
formula and the marvel method for making
movies isn't necessarily a bad thing
in the tv shows you have more time and
you have more to work with
and so if anything the tv show should
kind of be deviating away from the
marvel formula and the marvel method
where they try different things and
focus on new things and while that was a
great aspect of the show especially
oscar isaac kind of bouncing back and
forth between the mark spector and steve
grant personas that was really cool
everything else felt pretty cookie
cutter having said that
it was you know it's not particularly
memorable right there's nothing about
this that was just like man this is
mind-blowing however there were some
cool points in this so the fact that we
actually got to see amit was really cool
there was a part of me that was afraid
that we weren't going to um that we were
never actually going to see the physical
embodiment of ammit returning in the
world i do love the idea that moon
knight itself is focusing more on like
the earthly pantheon of gods as opposed
to any beings that may exist out there
in the realm and the you know whatever
is going on um i do hope that somebody
like honshu does make a return and thor
god and thunder if for no other reason
or thor 11 thunder if for no other
reason than the fact that basically we
would we would end up finding out konchi
was killed by gore the god butcher that
would be really really cool i don't know
that's necessarily going to be the case
and in fact i don't think that was the
case in marvel comics i don't think gore
killed konchu in the comics i know the
chaos king did well hell the chaos king
killed everybody in comics but i don't
know if uh if gore killed konchu at all
remember off top my head um but it would
be cool to see that i think the bigger
benefit to moon knight as a whole is
really just that focusing on the godly
pantheon basically saying like there are
egyptian gods who exist in the marvel
cinematic universe thor love and thunder
is obviously going to give us the greek
gods we already know about the uh the
the asgardian gods right from there and
i don't know if it'll be something
that'll be tapped into in uh in the miss
marvel tv show i highly doubt it that
show feels more like a a show rooted in
perhaps in human technology or something
like that but it would be cool to see
like vishnu and people along those lines
right whatever kind of beings exist out
there that are part of like the hindu uh
mythology and whatnot because that's
really the bigger picture here when it
comes to beings like mephisto nightmare
cathone all those guys they all
originate on earth right they they all
originate whether it's because they were
kind of dreamed into existence by
humanity or whatever it is humanity's
fears coalesced in a human form or i'm
sorry in a physical form they all
basically originate with humanity itself
it's not necessarily like like mephisto
and and nightmare and those guys are not
as necessarily on the nose as somebody
like cathone who was an elder god and
then somebody like uh like like honshu
who was basically a result of or the
offspring of amun ra who was the being
that actually ended up destroying or at
least banishing cathode or sitting athon
fleeing for his life more or less it's
not necessarily that they're not
necessarily that closely linked but it
would be cool to see but it would be
cool to see them focusing more on the on
the earthly gods but on the main show
itself you know it was it was cool i
will say leila's costume when she was an
avatar that costume was amazing oh my
god i love the way she looked it was
phenomenal right like as soon as she
shows up and you know what she reminds
me of those of you guys who ever who
read marvel comics would she had the
wings and everything she reminded me of
archangel when he was when he was the
horseman death for apocalypse she kind
of reminded me of him minus the blue
skin and you know all the dark tones and
everything but she looked phenomenal she
looked gorgeous in that whole that whole
outfit so i was like damn that was great
i did love you know one of the things
that i thought was really really cool
was mark spector basically making amends
to steve grant and it kind of it brought
a little bit of a tear to my not gonna
lie
i got a little misty-eyed in that in
that moment right and i was reading the
comments in the last video and i know
some of you all said that like you kind
of shed a couple tears when like steve
grant was just locked down in the sands
right like we needed basically was
essentially trapped there we presumed he
was going to be there and they were
going to kill off his personality but
that was really interesting i really
enjoyed that that discussion the two of
them had where mark specter and i i kind
of have to believe mark specter wasn't
really just making amends to steve grant
he was kind of making amends for
everything he'd done which i thought was
a a pretty a pretty awesome deal now
here's here's the big thing right here's
the the really big thing here everything
else in the show really just kind of
fell down into the normal marvel formula
i wish we'd gotten a chance to see bast
um i think that was just a great missed
opportunity here because remember the
panther goddess bass while she is
technically the patron goddess of the
wakanda clan or i'm sorry the the
panther clan in wakanda she started out
as an egyptian goddess and so i think it
would have been cool to see some kind of
reference to her i know that like over
the course of of some of the episodes
people were saying like well there was a
statue that looked like bass right and
different things like that i don't know
if the directors confirmed anything but
to see bass actually have
or at least appear in some capacity the
biggest problem that you have there is
technically the earthly avatar of bast
is the black panther and so unless the
black panther appeared there which if
chadwick boston was still alive that
would have been a phenomenal cameo tell
me it wouldn't right tell me like when
they were all gathering around in the in
the temple initially and like arthur
harrow was on was on trial and they were
like arthur herrera are you going to
bring back emmett he's like of course
not they're like see he's innocent like
you know when they had that whole that
whole scene there it would have been
kind of amazing like not even kind of it
would have been phenomenal to see
chadwick boseman there as one of the
avatars and to see him as like the
avatar of bass even if he was only in it
for like five minutes right for that
just one sequence and then he along with
the other avatars leaves that would have
been it it would have been amazing oh my
god the internet would have exploded if
that had happened god it would have been
great unfortunately of course we didn't
necessarily get to see that and i think
it's for a couple reasons one obviously
of course chadwick bossman is not with
us anymore and i think that marvel
because of all the stuff going on with
reshoots and everything i don't know if
they've officially figured out who the
new black panther is going to be yet i
know they had i think sheree lined up i
think with everything that was popping
off with her with letitia wright now
they're they're moving over to the guy
who played mbaku his name escapes me but
he's a phenomenal actor um so i'm not
really sure exactly how things are going
on there and even as far as the moon
night show i think they i think the
director or the creator came out and
intentionally said we're not trying to
lock it down in any particular place in
the mcu it just kind of exists out there
in the mcu which i think is a bit of a
problem um and maybe we'll address that
in like a future video but uh but
regardless um i think that that it would
have been cool to see a little more of
like bass even just like a reference or
something along those lines that i would
have enjoyed more over the course of the
show
now having said all of that um here's
the thing let's talk about jake lockley
for a second you know kind of circling
back to this because
again with the character of jake lockley
i know that between episodes five and
six it looks like they've changed things
so that instead of it being the series
finale it's the season finale so i guess
we're gonna get a season two and the
post-credits scene was interesting
enough right where you basically had
arthur harrow who was in the asylum and
then he was taken out of the asylum and
he's in in the limousine and basically
khan is writing and jake lockley's
driving and then jake lockley is the one
who killed him um i mean obviously that
whole the whole context of that
post-credit scene was basically designed
to illustrate that jake lockley was the
one who was popping up whenever mark
spector and steve grant were essentially
blacking out he was the one that was
basically willing to do things that
konchu wanted him to do or wanted mark
to do but mark simply couldn't bring
himself to do right so obviously jake
locklear is a darker side the fact that
jake lockley's got darker colors
indicates that jake lockley's color is
probably black right he was wearing what
was in effect an all-black suit for the
most part or a black outfit rather so he
probably turns into like a black version
of moon knight right darker
darker the darker outfit like a black
outfit and that kind of a thing having
said that i get what they were going for
and i get that if they do if we do end
up getting a season two that will likely
end up seeing jake lockley in season two
but i really feel like this was a missed
opportunity
to give us the character of jake at
least to give us some perspective of of
what we would what we could get in
season two um because i think that the
the best moment to have shown him would
have been in that final fight right that
last little fight right there where
you've got like ahmed and you've got uh
khanshu who are facing off against each
other and and things are popping off
they're like these giant this giant
alligator finding this giant skeleton
people like what in the hell is going on
you know like all that kind of stuff in
that moment when when literally mark
specter is being overpowered by arthur
harrow and basically jake lockley pops
up at the moment we would expect him to
where as we'd stated previously jake
lockley manifests when steve grant and
mark specter can't handle the situation
that would have been a great time to
show it now because steve grant and mark
spector don't know about jake lockley
what they easily could have done here is
just had the likely personality manifest
and then make some kind of offhanded
remark where he was talking more to
himself than he was to mark specter or
steve grant and say don't worry chaps
i'll take it from here and then actually
let us see you know jake lockley
overpowering all those guys because at
the very least it would have given us
what it was that we were looking for but
it would have given us just enough to
know
what jake lockley was capable of because
there's still questions that we don't
have the answer to involving jake
lockley the perfect example of this is
one that a lot of you guys pointed out
down in the comments section when you
had that scene in the afterlife when you
had mark and he had steve who were
basically going into those different
rooms and one of those rooms where
presumably everybody that mark specter
killed but a lot of you guys looked at
that and you said there was a kind of
sense of
almost kind of surprise on his face like
did i really kill this many people but
it's one of those things where he also
talked to steve and he told him he was
you know when steve was like like these
are all the people you killed like how
do you remember them all and the
response of mark was well try killing
somebody and see if you can forget their
face so it is a little murky we don't
necessarily know if it was exactly jake
lockley who was involved in that maybe a
few of them uh just based on that line
alone it could be one of those
circumstances where mark was quote
unquote protecting
steve grant either that or mark doesn't
know that jake lockley exists and so who
else would it have been if it wasn't
steve grant right so he's like i mean i
guess i did you know so nonetheless it's
one of those little little interesting
things but we did get those those kind
of little moments here and there and
those little things that teased into it
because then you look at the whole thing
with uh with rob bushman right that's
still exceedingly murky we still don't
know exactly how those events unfolded
we saw the whole scene in the afterlife
and again it was seemingly mark saying
yes i'm the one who did it and maybe it
really maybe that really is the case
right that mark tried to save them but
raw bushman killed everybody before he
had a chance to do it and then he ended
up at the statue of konshu who knows
right it could be one of those things
where mark specter blacked out thought
maybe steve grant took over or something
along those lines whatever the case is
jake likely somehow manifested again not
the most concrete evidence ever but
there are still some some murky
situations where we don't know if it was
mark spector or jake lockley so that
could have definitely been our mystery
and intrigue but i think that not
showing us jake doing his thing was a
real missed opportunity here because i
feel like what's going to happen is by
the time we get to the second season if
we get one and we end up seeing some
scene with jake lockley where like he
just starts unleashing hell by then
people are going to be like i mean i
don't really care anymore like i wanted
to see him before i don't know if i want
to see him now and if the context of the
situation isn't equal to the first
season in terms of like the severity and
the significance and that kind of a
thing it'll be a kind of showcasing
that'll essentially fall flat that's
kind of what i'm afraid of people will
be like i mean that's cool i guess you
know whatever whereas now in the moment
people wanted to see jake lockley right
they wanted to see that now again as far
as i'm as far as i'm aware it was only
between episodes five and six that they
basically said like it's the season
finale and not the series finale so it
could have been one of those things
where jake lockley was just kind of a
personality that was out there and was
teased and the decision to make a second
season was not launched until or at
least introduced until after the show
was effectively done right after it was
done like being recorded and filmed and
everything and they're like well
actually people seem to dig it and they
really want the jake lockley thing so
let's just do a second season when we
give them jake lockley we can't do it
now we already filmed everything
maybe that's that's that's what they're
going for uh because maybe the entire
intention was for jake lockley to always
kind of be this this mysterious
personality right this mysterious third
man that we never really knew anything
about and we wouldn't find out about him
until the post-credits scene at the end
of the show i don't think that's the
wisest decision but nonetheless right
just kind of speculating here i mean
until the director or the creator comes
out does an interview and says well
here's how things actually unfolded with
the whole jake lockley situation i don't
know if they have or not we won't know
definitively really until season two
kicks off so i don't know i mean at the
end of the day the show was not terrible
that's one of the things that i want to
specify here the show was not terrible
by any standard of measurement right i
don't think it was bad i think that it
got a little bit of a slow start but so
did one division right the first two
episodes of one division lost a ton of
people and then they ended up coming
back later on in the show but had no
idea what was going on because they
foolishly dropped off in the first two
episodes so you know it's one of those
things where the show started off a
little slow by the time it got to the
end it definitely picked up but it
definitely picked up and as we mentioned
it it had the kind of you know the
marvel ending right the standard marvel
formula which again i think in terms of
tv shows is something they should start
to sort of deviate away from and focus
on maybe you know something a little bit
different right because it's enough to
get in movies and when you get it in
shows that's when it really starts to
wear thin but outside of that i mean the
show was fun and it was great i had a
great time watching it uh where would
you know in terms of how i would rank it
um
i would put it ahead of falcon in the
winter soldier but i would put it behind
one division loki and what if right so
i'd say it's like my fourth favorite
show um honestly i feel like it's gonna
be a tall order to make a show that's
better than one division and loki
i'm gonna be honest with you guys that's
gonna be a tough one uh i'm not saying
they can't but i think i moon night i
don't think was ever going to be that
show um if they end up doing a team up
show with the midnight suns that could
be phenomenal uh but whether that'll
take place or not you know involving the
midnight suns as we know them i'm not
entirely sure because technically
morbius is part of the team but he's i
guess kind of off in his own universe
maybe i don't know sony doesn't know
marvel doesn't know nobody knows right
maybe he is maybe he's not who knows and
honestly who cares movie was awful so
there's my review people have been
asking me for a review about morbius
it's a movie that exists sony made it
and now we're here so with that being
said guys we're going to bring this
video to an end
thank you all for watching let me know
down in the comments what you guys think
about the moon night show and i will
catch you all later
peace